marci the most important thing is that
you start your own business
and let you do it as quick as you can
you want to do before you have
obligations you want to do before you
start thinking you should be having
children you want to do it before you
have a house mortgage to pay the most
important decision is not how you do it
but that you do it and do it right away
the minute you start thinking about
something too long the chances that you
do it go down exponentially by the
minute so you got to get out there and
do who cares if you borrow money from a
bank let me tell you something very few
people can build a business without
borrowing money from a bank and it's
like putting a gun to your own head you
owe money man you're gonna run like
crazy to make sure it really works
pressure is a great thing in life and
that's just one piece of pressure and it
gets you to discovering yourself the
gifts that you didn't even know you had
when your backs against the wall I'm a
total believer in going for it
flatout with as much pressure as you can
because with the great majority of
people who are supposed to be
entrepreneurs it brings out the best of
them get out there and do it and then
worry about the details later
well you no longer the same hard to get
along right now for a small business
owner you're starting to come oh you're
trying to come up with an idea how do
you get the capital to start that
business first of all if you're starting
a business and you take out a loan
you're more on right because you're it
there's so many uncertainties involved
with starting a business yet the one
certainty that you will have to have is
paying back your loan and the bank
doesn't care about your business or
whoever you borrow from unless it's
family doesn't care about your business
you know and so it's just a complete
conflict so whatever what's your small
business entrepreneur 99% of small
businesses you can start with next to no
capital it's more about effort you know
small businesses don't fail for lack of
capital they fail for lack of brains
they fail for lack of effort
most people just aren't willing to put
in the time to work smart I mean they
they they go for it in a lot of cases
but they just don't recognize how much
works involved and
and if you do the preparation if you
know if you start a business you better
know your your industry and your company
better than anyone in the whole wide
world
because you're competing and to think
that whoever it is you're competing with
is just gonna let you come in and take
their business obviously that's naive
and I think most people don't recognize
that if you're going to compete with me
and one of my businesses you better
realize that I'm working 24 hours a day
to kick your ass my intention with this
video was it's very understanding not
fighting I want you to see that it's not
one point of view or the other you can
pull and learn from both especially the
one that you don't immediately resonate
with embrace the genius of the end